do you need shots of ordinary people
doing things for your next commercial we
got that b roll we got that b roll two
men pointing at an office file we got
that b roll car Gibson hitting a
game-winning home run the ad a World
Series no that's too specific
that is not b-roll so come on down to a
b-roll warehouse just kidding that's
b-roll
I fooled you see that's how good I'll be
role is tell my wife I'm gonna be 30
minutes late while my husband I'm not
surprised tell my wife if she has a
problem with my work schedule she's more
than welcome to get a job of her own
message from your husband
I appreciate you [ __ ] what did he
actually say please don't drag me into
this Siri call my husband there's a cry
across the heartland learning for the
days gone by and a little Gordon Indiana
they're happy and I'll tell you why
bugs they love [ __ ]
transform your look the way celebrities
do with this beauty industry secret
that's now available for the first time
ever introducing Photoshop by ad obey
finally look the way you've always
dreamed my skin feels like plastic time
before cellphones computers
refrigerators time before clothing give
me simple attempts hey do you want to
feel so energetic try power thirsts
energy drinks for people who need
gratuitous amounts of energy with all
new flavors like chocolate chocolate
energy it's like adding chocolate to an
electrical store sound the alarm
you're gonna be uncomfortably energetic